On the 19th of June the oceangate submersible
began its descent to the Titanic’s fractured
remains here, in the north western atlantic.
With a descent rate of 55 metres per minute
it would take the submersible 70 minutes to
reach its destination.
With each passing minute the equivalent of
5.3 atmospheres of pressure would be added
to the subs hull.
By the time it reached its target depth the
weight of 366 of earth’s atmospheres would
be attempting to crush it.
Applied to just an area a little larger than
an A3 piece of paper, that’s equivalent
to the thrust of a Saturn V F1 engine.
Pressing in from all directions.
An hour and 45 minutes into the dive.
At the bottom of the Ocean.
3800 metres down.
With this immense pressure bearing down on
its hull.
The oceangate submersible lost contact with
the surface.
We now know the submersible imploded, a sudden
catastrophic collapse.
A tragic accident, however any composite material
engineer could have predicted this failure,
and they did.
I worked as a composite design engineer and
completed my master’s thesis in composite
failure prediction.
So, let’s dive into the questionable engineering
decisions that Oceangate made that led to
a tragic accident.
With that pressure comes some extreme design
challenges.
Oceangate’s Titan submersible consists of
two titanium end caps, one with a large acrylic
window, joined to a filament wound carbon
fiber reinforced epoxy hull.
[REF]
Inside the submersible is pretty barebone.
Some screens that are fed data from cameras
from the outside.
The four electric thrusters are controlled
with, from what I can tell, a third party
gamecube controller.
Many people are focusing on this part of the
design, but that’s the least of my concerns.
We will be focusing on one design aspect of
this submersible, the composite hull.
Carbon fibre composites aren’t really known
for their compressive strength.
They work best in tension.
Great for airplanes that are pressurised from
the inside.
Where the pressure inside the fuselage works
to expand the circular cross section, putting
the fibres in tension.
For a submarine, the pressure will work to
compress the hull, placing the fibres primarily
under compression.
This immediately set off alarm bells in my
mind when I heard of the missing submarine,
so I began digging into their justification
for using the material.
Oceangate chose this carbon fibre composite
primarily to benefit from its natural buoyancy.
These types of subs actually want to be as
close to neutrally buoyant as possible.
Meaning the weight of water they displace
weighs about the same as the vehicle itself.
Minimising the energy needed to rise or sink
in the water.
This means to surface in an emergency they
don’t need power, they just drop ballasts
that make them positively buoyant and they
just float to the surface.
The carbon fibre composite can be lighter
and thus helps achieve this neutral buoyancy
target.
Typically submarine hulls are made from steel
or more recently titanium, but in order to
achieve the desired buoyancy they need foam
outer layers.
OceanGates CEO Stockton Rush, who was inside
the submersible stated that they wanted to
skip this foam layer because it added to costs.
That isn’t necessarily an evil thing if
the composite is up for the job.
This is where things get iffy, oceangate had
no idea whether it was up to the task or not,
and we know this because they admit in their
own blog post justifying their decision to
not test their vehicle with a regulatory body.
[REF].
The now removed blog entry read:
Most major marine operators require that chartered
vessels are “classed” by an independent
group
Classing assures ship owners, insurers, and
regulators that vessels are designed, constructed
and inspected to accepted standards.
Classing may be effective at filtering out
unsatisfactory designers and builders, but
the established standards do little to weed
out subpar vessel operators The vast majority
of marine (and aviation) accidents are a result
of operator error, not mechanical failure.
As a result, simply focusing on classing the
vessel does not address the operational risks.
Now, I would have thought this wouldn’t
need pointing out, but the fact this glaring
red flag has been written on their own website
for everyone to see, and several extremely
wealthy and successful people didn’t seem
to think it was an issue seems to suggest
otherwise.
Perhaps most submarine failures occur due
to operator error precisely because they have
undergone rigorous testing and certification.
The comparison to aviation is also just a
wild can of worms that we have very recent
catastrophic accidents to compare to, where
manufacturers willfully circumvented regulatory
procedures.
These aren’t procedures created as some
kind of unnecessary inconvenience to inventors.
They are very useful guidelines and testing
procedures to prove you have not missed some
catastrophic failure mode in your design,
and that’s exactly what happened.
One failure mode is unique to composite materials
in deep sea applications.
Some of the first evidence we got for it was
glass fibre reinforced deep sea piping.
It’s called snap buckling, or delamination
coupled buckling failure mode.
For thin walled pressure vessels the failure
mode is simply buckling, where the pressure
simply caves the entire wall in, but here,
because the wall thickness is so large to
deal with the immense pressure of the deep
sea the failure mode gets more complicated.
This failure mode is characterised by delamination
of the internal layer of the pressure vessel,
basically the inside of the pressure vessel
suddenly peels away from the rest of the wall,
leading to catastrophic failure of the overall
structure.
The exact mechanisms of the failure mode are
not entirely well understood, as stated in
this 2022 research paper titled “A Review
on Structural Failure of Composite Pressure
Hulls in Deep Sea”.
[REF] It states, in its conclusion
“investigations on this subject have remained
at theoretical level.
There is still very little research in this
area in recent years.”
So, I am assuming whoever engineered this
pressure vessel did at least the same level
of research as a YouTuber who wrote a script
on the subject in two days.
They must have at least been aware of this
problem.
A failure mode like this is going to be exacerbated
by gradual damage incurred through cyclical
stresses, like those experienced when diving
to the depths of 4000 metres and resurfacing
again.
They have done that at least 50 times with
this vessel, without ever fatigue testing
it.
Per their own admission they did not undergo
industry standard classifications, but they
did do their own classification test.
One test, stated on that blog post once again.
“A licensed marine surveyor will witness
a successful dive to 4000 metres, inspect
the vessel before and after the dive, and
provide a Statement of Fact attesting to the
completion of the dive test plan.”
That is simply not adequate.
Anything undergoing repeated stress cycles
like this needs to be fatigue tested.
Like the test airplane manufacturers do on
wings where they flex the plane's wings thousands
of times on the ground.
They designed this thing essentially with
computer modelling with no real world testing.
Composite materials are incredibly difficult
to model in computer software.
Composite materials are far more complicated
than homogeneous materials like steel, where
the material properties are the same in all
directions and in all regions of the material.
Composites are composed of fibre bound together
by a matrix material like epoxy.
If we were to zoom into a small cross section
of this, we may see something like this.
Some fibres, some of them could be touching
without any matrix between them, some could
be spaced further apart, and there can also
be empty voids that the epoxy didn’t manage
to fill.
We can simulate a small section like this
independently to help analyse some failure
modes, such as delamination.
However if we want to zoom out and test a
larger section we often need to average the
material properties in some way or else the
simulation will take too long to run.
My own master thesis tried to combine the
two by embedding a fibre and matrix cell within
an averaged composite material.
There are specialised softwares that can model
different fibre orientations, but they are
still very much an estimation.
You need to back this up with physical testing.
Something OceanGate didn’t do.
There are more signs of incompetent use of
composites.
For a critical structure like this, I would
very much recommend curing it in an autoclave.
That’s basically a pressurised oven that
helps push those voids I mentioned earlier
out of the epoxy resin.
Autoclaves are expensive, and can be difficult
to find ones large enough to fit something
like this, but it’s nice to not have air
bubbles in a pressure vessel keeping you alive.
However, it wasn’t used for this pressure
vessel.
It was simply bagged and cured, a cheaper
alternative.
Spencer Composites was commissioned to make
the composite hull and their CEO was interviewed
back in 2017 in a compositesworld article.
He seems very aware of the immense design
challenge he was handed, and he does mention
that the porosity of the cured pressure vessel
was assessed to be less than <1%.
“Less than 1% voids” doesn’t exactly
inspire confidence.
Is it 0.99% or 0.0001% porosity?
That’s exactly the type of defect that’s
going to increase the risk of snap buckling
as voids can be propagation sites for delamination.
The blog post goes on to dismiss classification
tests as unsuitable for innovative designs,
which is just complete narcissistic nonsense.
This isn’t innovative.
They have just made the pressure vessel from
a carbon fibre composite, using known manufacturing
practices, and started charging rich people
250,000 dollars to risk their lives in it.
Innovation would be creating that pressure
vessel and testing it.
Figuring out the causes of snap buckling and
advancing material science for all mankind.
This is profiteering, not innovation.
To eliminate all doubt that this company has
willfully ignored standard safety practices.
This court case from 2018 was brought against
oceangate by a former employee who was fired
shortly after raising concerns about the composite
hull.
Stating not enough was done to check for delaminations
and voids.
Oceangate argued that the technology to check
for voids and delaminations in a composite
this thick did not exist, and instead they
would use their acoustic monitoring system,
which essentially listens for the sounds of
fracture to predict failure.
But this is what a carbon fibre composite
fracture curve looks like.
It’s a cliff edge.
Sudden catastrophic collapse.
An acoustic monitoring system like this is
akin to setting up a camera to warn you thunder
is coming.
You will see the lighting before the thunder,
but the time between them is minimal.
Pure safety theatre.
It gets even worse.
On one test dive in the Bahamas, a submersible
expert could hear the cracking with his own
ears and warned Stockton Rush that it was
a sign of damage accumulating.
Stockton, once again, chose to ignore an expert's
advice.
So this acoustic monitoring system was purely
for marketing purposes.
To give customers, who don’t have the engineering
background to see through it, a false sense
of security.
I would attribute this to malice and greed,
but Stockton Rush chose to pilot this death
trap himself.
As the Hanlon’s Razor goes:
Never attribute to malice that which can be
attributed to stupidity.
There is this growing trend in engineering
of moving fast and breaking stuff.
Mostly driven by one overconfident CEO who
has, to be fair to him, succeeded in revolutionising
an entire industry with that ethos.
That incriminating blog post even mentions
SpaceX, Blue Origin and Virgin Galactic as
bastions of innovation for this move fast
and break things mantra.
Virgin Galactic too have blood on their hands,
with their 2014 in-flight break up, which
was attributed to inadequate design safeguards
and poor pilot training, along with a lack
of oversight from regulatory authorities.
This attitude is dangerous, and this won’t
be the last story of wealthy narcissistic
CEO’s putting lives at risk.
When a doctor is negligent to the safety of
their patients, they are liable for malpractice,
but the impact their incompetence has affects
one patient, when an engineer neglects their
responsibilities it can affect hundreds, thousands,
maybe even millions of people.
We need more people like David Lockridge,
the employee who was fired for raising concerns
over safety.
The very first video on this channel stated
our mission.
To inspire the next generation of engineers,
but it’s more than just inspiring engineers,
we need engineers going into the most impactful
industries.
To solve the largest problems facing our civilization.
You’ve probably heard a lot of career advice:
‘follow your passion’, ‘do what you
love’, ‘take the initiative’, etc. etc.
But a lot of the advice out there doesn’t
take into account the best available evidence
we have for what actually makes for a high
impact and fulfilling career.
Today's sponsor, 80,000 Hours is a nonprofit
that, for the last ten years, has been researching
the question of how you can find a fulfilling
career that does good, too.
Everything they publish is based on careful
consideration of the data, consultation with
experts, and taking into account the best
evidence they could find on the topic.
And because they take this evidence-based
approach, they are able to make concrete recommendations
on hard questions like:
Where should I work if I actually want to
make a positive difference in the world?
What are the most pressing problems facing
humanity today, and how might we solve them?
What can I do today to start planning a fulfilling
career?
They have published over 30 articles on one
incredible pressing issue, safety in the development
of AI.
They have a website with tons of collected
research on high-impact careers, a job board
which lists currently open roles they think
might help you have a positive impact, and
a podcast where they have conversations with
experts about the world’s most pressing
problems.
Everything they provide is free, forever,
because they’re a nonprofit - their only
aim is to help solve global problems by helping
people find the most impactful careers they
can.
If you join the newsletter now, you’ll get
a free copy of their in-depth research-led
career guide sent to your inbox - just sign
up at 80000hours.org/realengineering, or click
the button on screen now